what's up everyone welcome back to
visual effects Arts react and well you
might see my Bollywood glasses here but
uh we're not watching a true Bollywood
film it's something a little similar to
one it's actually a little movie may
have heard of it's called The Flash
I think this is cool man I love this
this is cool see now this has some
stylism to it that I really like and
we're not looking at a bunch of
different movies today we are looking at
only the flash this is a flash special
today I gotta say as far as a movie goes
it was kind of fun now there's the
effects on the other hand I think you're
gonna have a good time watching this
because there's there's a lot to unpack
whoa
whoa what crosses the line man let's
just say we're gonna take a little trip
on the Polar Express here
this is the opening of the movie This is
the first time we see him run that's
cool I love that Zoom effect that is
pretty sweet so it so is that weird you
guys that is going super fast but his
steps are in slow motion yeah and I know
what they're doing basically the idea is
that he's moving so fast that friction
doesn't affect him I believe so he's
like kind of Gliding Over it but what's
weird is then you kind of expect it to
be more of like an ice skating motion or
something but instead you just get like
this Run Cycle that is gliding over that
just looks like a poor visual effect
shot and that's always the question that
I come back to it's like just because
it's right doesn't mean it looks good
and if it doesn't look good should it be
the final shot because at the end of the
day superheroes don't exist just make
something that looks cool and
everybody's satisfied
I mean that's cool though I love that
skidding to a stop there like all that
electricity the energy if I was in the
theater watching this movie and I'd be
like I'd still be into it right now yeah
I watched this movie for the first time
last night I've heard so much about the
visual effects I thought I would dive in
and the reality is after watching it
last night I realized there's a lot more
to dissect than I initially expected
okay so if you'll do me the honor hold
on to your Huggies because the first
thing we're gonna break down is this
baby scene
this is a huge
oh wow look at this by the way his head
is totally cut off from the body they're
literally rotoing his head maybe with an
actual mask and then the whole suit from
the chin down is a CG body yeah you guys
actually animated kind of separately
it's the same sort of effect we saw back
in like civil war with Iron Man and
Roadie where it's like you have a full
CG suit but they're trying to marry that
with real photography of a face it's
like it technically works but we can
still tell something's up I don't know
it's the collapse of the East Wing
okay this is Bollywood this is Bollywood
yeah
babies oh my gosh oh my God
oh I see what's happening so like he
needs more calories so time's starting
to speed back up yes it's an emergency
but all these babies are gonna need more
and there's literally flying scalpels
and then there's alcohol that one's
gonna get smushed yeah okay this is
insanity mush stabbed and drunk his head
size is yeah all over the place they big
headed him man like he's got a bigger
head when he's eating the last piece of
that candy did you see that no oh there
we go oh wow dude well that's because
his neck is like I think that's true
looks a little bigger right now that's
like a floating head it's like literally
a floating head that's huge it's like
the bed's like doing this while the body
sits still his head is too big man about
double the volume dude that's not that's
laughs
I think the weakest thing out of this
whole sequence are the babies in my
opinion the babies are just not
realistic for one moment throughout this
entire sequence they are the they are
literally the weakest characters in the
scene too
physically and literally
like that that looks pretty good that's
a real baby no
no that is that's real baby the baby in
the microwave was not a real baby I was
just saying it didn't look terrible oh
wait oh yeah are you sure to me this
might be it might sound rude but this
looks like an elevated Son of the Mask
baby I was thinking oh Warner Brothers
Looney Tunes it felt like they were
trying to go that direction where it's
like a Looney Tunes goofy kind of thing
but it's again rooted in reality to a
higher degree to where you're supposed
to care about all this stuff and it's a
weird like those don't really go
together very well I don't even know if
I would call the majority of it like bad
CG it's just it's so Preposterous that
you have to go okay so this is CGI and
no quality of visual effects are going
to make you go oh this is real like look
at the ground crumpling beneath his legs
as he's running away like that's some
incredibly High detail simulation work
going on and everything looks amazing
and yet I'm sitting here being like
yeah you don't care that's the reality
behind it it's like I was I was racking
my brain because again I was looking at
the visual effects I was thinking the
vast majority are very well done the
babies of course draw the attention and
human faces like we've explored many
times is like the hardest thing to do
it's a dangerous road to go down yeah
because you're already as an idea so
apart from what is possible to think
about that you need to Anchor that as
much as you can to reality to make us
care I mean that's what you see with RR
right the visual effects were not Avatar
quality but entertaining so entertaining
to where you don't even think about it
you're like yeah what a cool concept
yeah I think they were kind of hoping
that that would still apply here with
the creative ways he's saving the babies
but I don't know it's all just a little
too out there for me yeah look as we've
seen in the previous clip babies they're
useless they're loud they're constantly
in danger you know what's not raycons
let me tell you about it raycon's
everyday earbuds look feel and sound
better than ever with optimized gel tips
for the perfect in-ear fit these earbuds
are so comfortable they will not not
fudge babies make a lot of noise these
remove the noise baby sound proof
listening babies cost a lot these are
half the price of other premium earbuds
babies have a 30 second attention span
these last for eight hours and will do
whatever you say I left my earbuds in
here and they're good kids and they'll
always be exactly where I left them
sound asleep in the crib doing what
they're supposed to do recharging to
serve you now I don't have babies but
given that the quarter office can
sometimes be just as loud wearing
raycons helped me lock in to make sure
my shots get delivered on time every
time and for those of you out there
whose babies are all grown up there is a
back to school sale happening right now
20 off site-wide with free shipping so
go to buy recon.com Corridor crew or
just click the link in the description
down below to finally get the piece that
you deserve now let's get back to Ezra
Miller's
seriously there's two of them now more
than we ever really wanted I did wow
so wait there's a bunch of Clone shots
here yeah because for a lot of this
movie there are two Ezra Miller's okay
there's some wild comping going on yeah
I'm getting some senses my spider sense
is tingling they probably have like a
stand-in actor with everything but
they're replacing the head headphone
guys who I'm talking about yeah yeah
see like oh yeah digital headphones
digital head
the headphones are the scene that's
actually a really good idea whoa whoa
whoa that's the shot to look at that's
the shot where he's behind him there
watch the neckline and the headphones
they're just floating around on their
own they're just going haywire yeah
you're right yep yep I'm also getting a
feeling that his whole body there is
actually digital yeah I think you're
right dude so I'm I'm actually now
becoming more and more convinced that
Barry Allen with the headphones is
completely digital throughout this
entire camera move the hair work is very
good very good very very yeah very you
think that's a CGI phase I do I actually
do and it might be utilizing some deep
faking aspect as well on top but I'm
kind of with rent on that I think it's a
full CG thing because again his blocking
the blocking is dynamic for who the
original Berry and for the camera but
the CG character is steadfast posted up
everything's moving around that so yeah
if you want to stand in eye line of a
tennis ball or something he can act to
that we can move super dynamically and
then just replace the thing that is in
that location in space I think that
would be the way to do it super
ambitious man like honestly the end
result is very good like this is the
most impressive thing I've seen from the
whole movie so far yeah I would love to
see a breakdown for this shot yeah I
would love to yeah I think the point is
that there's a bunch of different ways
you can do the sequence but it's good
enough that we don't actually know and I
think the fact that we're even debating
it this heavily is indicative it was
like okay that was great you know you've
got us thinking about it as opposed to
just going oh CG baby
[Music]
let's go let's let's freaking open again
I want to see him vibrate through the
door dude I know that's coming up next
that's like okay that actually is a
really cool
a Quantum tunneling
tunneling the cool concept what is
quantum tunneling
when you vibrated through a door
or anything for that matter I mean every
is made of atoms right but atoms are
also like almost a hundred percent just
empty space So in theory you can have
stuff just Quantum tunnel through I mean
yeah if you look at football you know
you got people defending people on
offense the offensive people try to Juke
them you know get out of the way break
the defender's ankles if you do that
with atoms you just keep juking back and
forth you can eventually vibrate your
way through that is actually a really
good
description yeah maybe how this can work
look at that let's see this I want to
see this this is gonna I'm already
getting cool Vibes here
come baby look at this I think this is
cool man I love this this is cool also
technically they made the door about
like 10 microns thick like you can count
the atoms that they go through it's just
it should be so much longer than like
they should be doing this for hours
all right nerd all right
I'm trying to enjoy this movie
it's a sweet shot
please leave a review on IMDb just
saying not enough microns
I want them to release the more microns
cut
requirements
what oh oh yeah baby yummy that was a
wonky face he's all pasty so that's real
Berry on the left Digi Berry on the
right yeah Digi Berry 100
dude that's cool I like this this is
cool okay that's freaking gummy Gumby
boy see now this has some stylism to it
that I really like yeah oh what the heck
that's when he breaks through so now he
is essentially you know in the center of
time I believe the smearing nature of it
gives it style you know with a face
definitely well it's subjective it's
super subjective you know everything
else up to here like running fast is
like okay we'll do it fast with motion
blur but it's like all right how do you
show traversing a Quantum realm you know
it's like you have to make it up and you
have to make it interesting and I think
that's interesting
I mean this is an interesting shot but
it's a little like Polar Express right
now yes
yes it's very polar expressy this
[Music]
I remember that CGI baby from yeah Polar
Express
[Laughter]
I told you they were compositing his
head in there
it's pretty good I'm like no
oh it's totally separated from his body
oh he's just dipping in and out dude
this whole movie is about floating heads
[Music]
whoa oh yes this is where this is where
it crosses the line man Polar Express
Superman we know Henry Cavill we know
what he looks like and you know what he
looks like without a mustache and that's
not what
I know
look like the rest of his body seems
fine but then he has his eyes have no
life also yeah there it's it's totally
expressionless if Henry Cavill was there
doing it he'd probably be making it like
a face you know like like oh or like
yeah or something like that or instead
of just you've never thrown a punch a
human expression that's the term yeah
that's right
this is a nasty Episode by the way we
are big very bad boys right now
[Music]
yeah
man that dummy is like the most
realistic thing in this whole scene
why aren't they using like the better
models don't they have like better like
Digi doubles for these multi-million
dollar actors you know the A-list Triple
A stars of the film like I think they
probably are using them are they using
them because it feels like maybe like a
like a different VFX house doesn't have
access to them no they they or is it the
VFX studios are very open about sharing
assets and whatnot so not having the
right model isn't the problem it's
interesting because there's an artist
Zach Mulligan who's credited on IMDb is
working on this film who came out to
talk about it because obviously when
films like this come out the vfxrs get
dumped on and it's like oh you guys suck
this is bad this that and the other and
while objectively it is distracting the
quality of it the reality is and what he
was just saying is like look in the VFX
world right now more than ever it's a
it's a race to the bottom as far as
bidding like houses are pitted against
each other you have to do it cheaper and
faster and then notes come down from the
top and the execs don't care at all
about your time working overtime working
weekends like they're like just get it
done by this deadline because at the end
of the day the shareholders of this kind
of stuff they don't care about the CG
quality will you the audience member eat
it if you will eat it and pay us for it
we'll just throw it your way so in a way
this backlash is to the benefit of VFX
artists because it's like look we're not
just going to keep taking this right
it's like at a certain point we expect a
certain quality and a certain care to be
given to the characters that we love so
I just on the record like yes we're
being harsh as to the end result but in
no way do I blame the visual effects
artists I don't think you guys do either
like this is this is a result of greed
but yeah the director Andy muschetti was
saying no it's supposed to look weird
like because it's his perspective if
it's like it's like a Time warped
Essence which I get for the orange glow
and the warpy air and stuff like that so
there's no way that's a really lame
excuse that's a really lame excuse also
what does it do to the Canon of The
Polar Express now like who's what
perspective are we watching this train
ride from is this is this Tom hanks's
perspective or the child if there was
the kid with the glasses in this
Carousel I would die but I mean at the
end of the day at the end of the day if
you're if you're directing this film and
you're given an option time and money
resource doesn't matter you say okay
we've got this massive Carousel of
possibilities and memories and actors
and you know cameos and whatever do you
want to be photo realistic or do you
want it to look like Polar Express
you're gonna pick
10 out of 10 times so we defend this now
yeah
this actually might have some of the
worst visual effects in any big bunch of
superhero movie in a long time that's a
good point but what I'm talking about is
right behind subscribe the person's face
right there that's so crazy uh subscribe
like And subscribe
oh
speaking of Burning Man yeah yeah
generic desert in the middle of nowhere
perfectly flat as far as the eye can see
whoa what the heck okay that's right
cool yeah that's sweet I don't know what
that was but that was cool he's cool
dude he grabbed a missile
and the missile is still thrusting yeah
dude
he's not
I kind of love that that's cool yeah
it's getting fused inside his arms
because that's like that's cool because
that's a novel thing to happen you know
we don't normally see that sort of like
fusing mechanic in movies like I like
that yeah this is a part of his arm now
really cool idea you know like there's a
lot of great stuff though there's a lot
of great stuff in this
[Music]
Museum of Fine Art
that's what we're calling that sequence
wait what are these spheres busting
through the wall these are the other
cycloramas or whatever they're called ah
I follow yeah yeah so this is where we
start getting into Cameo territory and
this this was one that I saw online a
lot mentioned like what are we doing
because these cameos don't actually
serve any real purpose for the story
it's more just like now it's it's Warner
Brothers execs going who else can we put
hey how do we feed them how do we feed
the fans who do they want to see so this
is like pure fan service territory this
is pure fans like look we break through
to this other universe that's colliding
who is it
silhouette reveal
oh Christopher Reeves Christopher Reeves
his Polar expression yeah Adam West Adam
West okay and then who else we got oh
this is a good one you'll like this one
[Music]
oh is that who I think it is
it is
who is it Sam it is oh my god wow
Nick Cage but he's fully digital yeah
like they he didn't film anything for
that then wow everyone's polar
expressified could these faces be better
probably if they had more time but they
didn't have more time and honestly I
think like they're working against
themselves a little bit with the
cinematography because at the moment
like when you see the first Nick Cage
one it's like okay cool that looks like
Nick Cage but then like the camera
orbits around them and you get the full
View and you're like oh wait this is a
3D model like there if they would have
left it at that it almost works yeah it
falls apart the moment the camera starts
orbiting around yeah and almost like
once the eyes stop glowing like this
this looks perfect I'm down I'm sold and
then oh oh yeah got The Uncanny eyes
yeah the glow hides The Uncanny and then
same thing with the Chris Reed thing too
it's just like it looks great at first
and then it starts spinning around them
and you're like oh I'm getting the three
like right there looks like footage
projected the hair looks great the
hair's fine I like that that's the other
thing I'm noticing like all the 3D
models of these people like the hair is
incredible but the faces are the thing
that pulls it back it's conceptually
this movie does so many cool things and
even in spite of all the shortcomings I
enjoyed my viewing experience I laughed
I had a good time I mean I didn't go in
expecting anything great personally this
is an example of visual effects work
that is suffering from the triangle of
expectation right it's it's cheap fast
and good you can pick two what we see in
the visual effects here is basically an
example of artists who don't have enough
time we know where the tech is and where
the abilities are of these artists and
when we see bad visual effects like this
I feel like the default result is to
blame the artist I'd argue a lot of the
stuff in this in this movie is great the
thing is for the whole digital human
thing when you're trying to recreate a
person you know not everyone can do that
it is the hardest thing to do in visual
effects and it's not even about like the
amount of time you have it's like a lot
of the best stuff you've seen in like
what Avatar that's proprietary yeah so
it's not like you can just hire another
VFX house to replicate that and when
you're setting yourself up for this it's
it's less about do you have the budget
or anything like that but it's like are
you even working with the right team for
this particular task you know we did
kind of make fun of a lot of these shots
and I feel kind of bad because we might
be making fun of something that like an
artist literally worked 80 hours in a
week to get that shot done and here we
are just making fun of it so I feel bad
but at the same time it's not their
fault like you're saying yeah
yeah yeah we just feel bad Nick okay we
feel bad all the time is there another
movie that you think needs a dedicated
episode breaking down everything from
just that one movie leave a comment down
below suggesting it and maybe we'll
dedicate a whole episode to it guys we
may not be wearing buttons but we're
buttoned up on YouTube we're in our best
behavior on the website though Corridor
digital.com we let loose a little bit
more check out extended episodes there
Corridor digital.com yeah you never
believe what Sam said oh it was bad I
couldn't believe it I stand by my words